[Music]
what's shaking twain hey i'm good on
anything just like gravy baby good to
see you my man you too man hey
i finally read prince and the popper oh
is that right
didn't get it
for reals
satire
i'm just pulling your leg oh man
i can't read hello and welcome to a new
episode of rt essentials i'm lord
garrett today we are talking about clubs
and who doesn't love being a part of a
club that sense of community
well not so fast because this is one of
the hardest clubs to get into when it
comes to the world of cinema to get into
this club your movie has to be so bad
like doesn't have a single positive
review bad so bad that they're actually
kind of worth watching that's right
today we are breaking down the rotten
tomatoes zero percent club and i'm 100
certain you're gonna love it
ballistic x versus sever
tracking target
oops
kicking things off is the 2002 action
thriller ballistic x versus sever this
movie comes from a thai film director
who goes by the name chaos and it
centers around former fbi manhunter
jeremiah x played by antonio banderas
after the mysterious death of his wife
he's become a bit of a recluse but is
blackmailed back into the service to
track down a rogue dia operative named
seva played by lucy liu as x and seva
square off they eventually figure out
that there's a much bigger villain at
play and they ultimately decide to team
up to fight their new common enemy while
also searching for the most deadly new
weapon on earth
sold despite what was considered pretty
solid star power at the time with
antonio and lucy this film could have
looked a lot different
drop your weapon
[Music]
okay along with having various working
titles along the way like legion and
gunner which let's be honest anything
would have been better than the title
that they went with wesley snipes and
jet li were once in talks to star and
later sylvester stallone and vin diesel
even dolph lundgren was once attached
and i gotta say x versus ivan drago
sounds just as good as x versus ever but
despite the popular names this movie did
have and not to mention a big studio
like warner brothers behind it it was
still universally panned by critics as
one of the worst films ever made
and for good measure it lost somewhere
around the 50 million mark thanks to a
poor box office oops and to go along
with the big old goose egg on the tomato
meter the consensus from critics is that
ballistic x versus sever is a startingly
inept film offering overblown
wall-to-wall action without a hint of
wit coherence style or originality
ouch
one missed call
[Music]
you're gonna want to put your phones on
silent for this next one because we are
dialing up the 2008 horror flick one
missed call this one is actually a
remake of japanese horror visionary
takashi mikey's 2004 film which is also
rotten although it had more than zero
percent and that film itself was based
on a novel directed by erica vallette
this version stars shannon soseman as
beth who witnesses the death of two
friends but learns that it's more than
just a tragic coincidence because days
before they died both victims received
voicemails on their boost mobile flip
phones by the way from their future
selves with details of their deaths
yikes here i thought that those messages
about my car's extended warranty were
bad
[Music]
which one
and while most people think beth is
crazy detective jack andrews played by
ed burns believes her so they work
together to try and unravel the mystery
behind the horrifying messages before
their own phone numbers come up
i think i just missed your call the
film's zero percent fate could have
possibly been avoided considering
guillermo del toro was offered the job
to direct but chose to focus on hellboy
2 instead plus ed harris and gabriel
byrne were both signed on but withdrew
for unknown reasons perhaps they got a
mysterious voicemail about how bad it
was gonna be
she's sassy today one missed call wasn't
screened for critics ahead of time which
is never a good sign but alas they did
get a hold of this clunker and hung up
some harsh critiques as it became the
worst reviewed film of 2008. the toronto
stars philip marchand said the best part
of the movie is the fact that at a
running time of an hour and a half it's
mercifully short with an overall
consensus from critics that this is one
of the weakest entries in the j horror
remake sweepstakes undone by bland
performances and shot-worn shocks a
thousand words laugh cry the close
cousins just let it out
ah
i've got a couple of hundred words
prepared for the next movie on this list
and that is 2012's a thousand words this
one stars eddie murphy as a selfish
fast-talking literary agent named jack
mccall who makes a bad deal with a new
age spiritual guru played by cliff
curtis and suddenly finds a magical
bodhi tree in his backyard with every
word jack speaks a leaf falls from the
tree until both of them are no more so
he has to learn how to pump the brakes
on his speech or his existence as he
knows it will make like a tree and leave
i'm not even sorry for that one
of course not speaking turns jack's life
upside down affecting everything from
his career to his marriage with carolyn
played by kerry washington who walks out
on him after thinking his sudden silence
is because he doesn't love her anymore
honey i just wanted to try to prove to
you that we could still have fun but i
guess we can't so
i'm so embarrassed the film with a
supporting cast that also includes alice
and jenny jack mcbreyer and john
witherspoon actually sat on a shelf for
four years before it was finally
released after getting caught up in the
separation of dreamworks from paramount
and viacom or maybe somebody could sense
the eventual zero percent score and hit
it behind some old crackers and a couple
of cans of tuna not a bad strategy
a thousand words only pulled in about
half of its 40 million dollar budget
earning full-on box office bomb status
and for good reason the consensus among
critics was that dated jokes because of
the four-year delay and removing eddie
murphy's voice his greater comedic asset
dooms this painful mess from the start
gotti
can i get a pass
back
swearing on your kid's grave
you won't kill me
how am i gonna kill the ghost
we'll have to be careful about what we
say about his next movie because you
know something about sleeping with the
fishes it's 2018's gotti this film not
only stars john travolta as infamous
crime boss john gotti but was also
directed by e himself kevin connolly it
follows a young john who found his way
into the gambino crime family after
being raised on the streets of new york
he eventually had the boss removed and
became the head of the very powerful
family but along the way he broke a vow
to not expose his kids to his profession
and his son john gotti jr eventually
takes dad's place i mean the family
business is the family business am i
right
i know you like john
hell i like jones when adam kneels out
of the picture paul just wants to
shake up the whole administration
travolta stars alongside his real life
wife kelly preston as gotti's wife
victoria in what would be the last film
that was released before her death the
project took over a decade to get off
the ground with various directors like
barry levinson and actors like pacino
and stallone rumored to be attached but
it ultimately became travolta's job to
lose because the gotti family personally
asked for him and they even lent many of
john gotti's accessories like ties and a
tweet overcoat for travolta to use in
the film and while actors like channing
tatum and dominic cooper were considered
to play john gotti jr the role
eventually went to little-known canadian
actor spencer franco to go along with a
consensus that simply reads forget about
it critics like johnny olixinsky from
the new york post said i'd rather wake
up next to a severed horse head than
ever watch gotti again and brian
talarico from roger ebert dot com adding
he may have been a murderer but even
gotti deserved better than this
well if i wasn't dead before
that just murdered me
pinocchio
[Music]
[Music]
i could tell you that this next film is
actually really good but i don't want my
nose to grow from telling a lie so i
won't i am talking about 2002's
pinocchio this film was written and
directed by and stars oscar winner
roberto benini and is based on the 1883
novel the adventures of pinocchio about
a magical log that falls off a wagon and
stops at geppetto's door the woodcarver
makes a puppet out of it and names it
pinocchio which then comes to life and
is a bit of a troublemaker
it was the most expensive production in
italian film history at the time with a
budget of about 45 million dollars and
while the film made just shy of that the
real issues came with the english dubbed
version of the film with brecken myers
stepping in to replace bernini's voice
as pinocchio and even though benini was
criticized for being too old to play
pinocchio maya was then criticized for
being too young to replace benini whoa
what a conundrum
uno
hey
[Laughter]
in fact the english dub version was
nominated for six rousey awards a first
for a foreign language film and took
home one for worst actor awarded to
roberto and brecken despite the critical
and commercial failure of the film that
didn't stop benini from getting involved
with another take on the famous
children's tale playing guppetto in
2019's pinocchio and while that version
is coming in fresh on the tomato meter
giving bernini a little bit of a
redemption critics won't be forgetting
the 2002 disaster or this face
any time soon
especially after reviews like this from
the san francisco chronicles edward
guffman who wrote what can one say about
a balding 50 year old actor playing an
innocent boy carved from a log and
overall critics consensus which calls it
an unfunny poorly made creepy vanity
project
super babies baby geniuses 2.
i'll do it
i'll finish them off
one day i will win
i will destroy you if it takes me
forever i don't know about you but the
next movie on this list is getting me
hungry for some pureed peas and
applesauce it's super babies baby
geniuses 2. yeah that meant that there
was a super baby's baby geniuses won yup
the 2004 family flick is the follow-up
to 1999's baby geniuses which also
happens to be rotten at a whopping two
percent on the tomato meter i suppose
that they assumed that things could only
get better from there what are you gonna
get a zero you did anyway this film
follows the events of the first film
where four babies can communicate with
each other using baby talk and holds all
kinds of knowledge and secrets they find
themselves having to use their special
abilities to stop a media mogul known as
kane played by john voigt who is on a
mission to crack the code to the baby
talk and alter the minds of children pro
tip just have fruit snacks on you all
the time that's all you need
this marked the final film for director
bob clark who directed the first film
and also a bunch of other films
including 80s classics porkys and a
christmas story but even with john
voight who went on to appear in many
more baby genius installments by the way
along with a cast that includes scott
baio and vanessa angel plus a cameo
appearance from oh town this film just
couldn't improve on the first film's 2
score along with earning less than half
of its budget back and being nominated
for worst picture at the razzie awards
the consensus from critics is that this
is a sequel offering further proof that
bad jokes still aren't funny when coming
from the mouths of babies with joanne
kaufman from the wall street journal
calling it unspeakably ghastly
yikes
apparently there's a new sequel in the
mix and it's just a bunch of millennials
talking in baby talk to their dogs
jaws the revenge
[Music]
the next film on this list was looking
for revenge but all it got was an invite
to the rotten tomatoes zero percent club
it's 1987's jaws the revenge produced
and directed by joseph sergeant this
marks the final film in the franchise
coming after the certified fresh
original jaws and two less successful
sequels although this one is a direct
follow-up to jaws too just ignoring the
events of jaws 3d
this time around chief brodie's widow
played by lorraine gary who briefly came
out of retirement to reprise the role of
ellen brody believes her family is
deliberately being targeted by another
shark in search of revenge after it
kills her son and then follows her to
the bahamas i mean who doesn't want to
go to the bahamas hello
[Applause]
one thing that potentially put this
movie on the fast track to zero percent
is the fact that the production itself
was fast-tracked taking less than nine
months to complete when the other three
films in the franchise took around two
years each and the result was the lowest
grossing film of the four some good did
come from jaws the revenge though
because it introduced us to a couple of
famous lines including the memorable
tagline of this time it's personal
because the other times it wasn't it was
just a shark being hungry
that's what sharks do they eat the other
line came from one of the film's stars
michael kane when he was asked about the
film in an interview and said i've never
seen it but by all accounts it is
terrible however i have seen the house
that built it and it is terrific
unlike my michael caine impersonation
the consensus from critics is that this
installment is a logical tension free
and filled with cut-rate special effects
a sorry chapter in a once proud
franchise
dark crimes
you're novel
same victim same location same means of
death
only a police officer the killer could
know those facts the details of the
murder were never published
so how do you know about that you really
want me to tell you i murdered daniel
did you this next movie could have
cashed in on the true crime craze that's
been going around on the media these
days but instead it ended up joining the
zero percent club and that is 2016's
dark crimes this film is based on a 2008
article from the new yorker about a
murder of a polish businessman by a
writer but it wasn't until three years
later after the crime that a detective
cracked the case when he read a crime
novel with depictions of a murder that
were too similar to be a coincidence jim
carrey stars as the detective in this
version of the story who takes on a
murder case that resembles a recently
published novel but what appears to be
an open and shut case ends up having an
even darker secret behind it you killed
daniel sadowsky and you made it look
like a subtle masochistic game that went
wrong that's what you say
no
that's what you say
that's what i write the film has had an
interesting ride to get to our zero
percent club including having roman
polanski once circling the project with
christophe walt attached to star morgan
freeman was also offered the lead role
before jim carrey was eventually cast
with greek film director alexandros
avranus at the helm dark crimes
premiered at the warsaw film festival in
october of 2016 under the name true
crimes but didn't find its way into
theaters until a limited release nearly
two years later and after a name change
the film received criticism for its
overly gloomy tone and bad pacing along
with the objectionable presentation of
abused women the consensus from critics
is that this is a rote unpleasant
thriller that fails to parlay its
compelling true story while richard
roper from the chicago sun times was
expecting more saying source material
with great dramatic potential talented
director and screenwriter intriguing
cast that's a promising menu but the end
product leaves a sour taste
the ridiculous six you're in for a real
tweet today this is gonna be so much fun
[Applause]
i'll just mess it with y'all i'm fine
there is a word i am thinking of to try
and describe this next film but i just
can't put my finger on it anyway this is
2015's the ridiculous six ridiculous
that's the word this western comedy
stars unsurprisingly adam sandler terry
crews george garcia taylor lautner rob
schneider and luke wilson as the
aforementioned six sandler plays tommy
an orphan raised by native americans who
discovers that he actually has five
outlaw half-brothers who all share the
same bank-robbing father played by nick
nolte so the six of them must set out to
find him why is this zero percent
the rest of the cast is a who's who of
sandler films with people like steve
bashemy david spade norm mcdonald and
john turturro and it also featured other
interesting names such as danny trejo
harvey keitel blake shelton and yes
vanilla ice actually frankly i think
them all doing the vanilla ice dance at
the end of the movie is worth at least
one percent oh no wait this movie is
straight up offensive
yep
now they call them smiley because even
when committing the most unspeakable
atrocities a cheerful grin never leaves
his face
all right just lift your tail from me
please
this film was in production with
columbia pictures paramount pictures and
warner brothers but it was eventually
dropped by all three and ended up at
netflix as part of adam sandler's
exclusive four movie deal with the
streaming giant and believe it or not
about a month after the title premiered
on netflix in december of 2015 they
announced that it had been viewed more
times in 30 days than any other film in
netflix history at the time
[ __ ] but despite that and the
idiocracy reunion between luke wilson
and terry crews critics just couldn't
stand this one like justin chang of
variety who called it a western send-up
so lazy and aimless it barely qualifies
as parody and the overall consensus from
critics is that this is standard couch
fare for adam sandler fanatics and must
avoid viewing for film enthusiasts of
every other persuasion
oh that's great actually gives me life
to quote my favorite vanilla eye song
though too cold too cold
red line
the final movie on this list arrived at
our zero percent club going at about 120
miles per hour it's 2007's racing
thriller redline this film which
borrowed its name from the original
working title of 2001's the fast and the
furious stars soap opera star nadia
bjorlin as natasha an aspiring singer
and skilled driver she starts doing
illegal street races for a wealthy music
producer played by eddie griffin and his
big betting millionaire friends but
things get even more dangerous for
natasha when one of the millionaires is
willing to do anything to get her racing
for him
redline was not only written and
produced by a guy named daniel sadek but
also funded by his own production
company at the time called quick loan
funding but wait there's more he also
used his own car collection in the film
going as far as to donate his porsche
carrera gt priced at over four hundred
thousand dollars to be crashed in one of
the many stunt sequences oh my oh my
goodness this guy was the movie oh and
one last thing he was engaged to nadia
berlin at the time and was trying to
help her get out of the soap opera world
oh my goodness you can't make this up
this film is directed by andy chang
known mostly for being a longtime
hollywood stunt man on films like
chongqi and the legend of the ten rings
and rush hour too but his action chops
weren't enough to save this flick which
wasn't screened for critics but pretty
much redlined as soon as they did get a
hold of it with a consensus that redline
has plenty of bad acting laughable
dialogue and luxury cars well that's our
list of the rotten tomatoes zero percent
club which might not be a fun club to be
a part of but hey this sure is fun to
talk about if it is the rotten tomatoes
zero percent club isn't it just
technically compost at this stage
thank you so much for checking out rt
essentials i'm more garrett and don't
lose all hope on film because there's a
lot of really good stuff out there i
know you keep talking about it
[Music]
[Music]